I want to acknowledge another co-host
who has joined us happy are you happy
his everything is a rescue you know I'm
big into rescue who are the bigger divas
all these fabulous animals you could
take care of or all of the fabulous
available roles these guys it's a very
convoluted complicated experience it's
still a hot crazy mess you also had a
scary moment when a car drove through
the front of your restaurant it looked
absolutely catastrophic but nobody got
hurt
thank God so it was anyone sitting at
that - yes they literally jumped up and
out the way there's always so much going
on even when you guys aren't filming
want you to see this Justin Bieber
working out I think right across the
street from me the Biebs you would think
he had a gym at home we're gonna say he
should come and just serve for cocktail
really but I think a couple of the
people there are friendly with him like
who just want to draw the line Lisa
Vanderpump zip it dearly beloved we are
gathered here today
what else can you tease for the new
season when people are getting married
the group's divided that was a catalyst
for a pretty kind of explosive season
this Vanderpump rules okay can you just
wake up and pretend you're interested
come on taking him to tell me I am a
liar
I got eyes would you ever return to that
show I can never say never about
anything I'm sure you've heard a little
bit about some of the drama well I just
heard a little bit about a little hookup
situation no comment on that now Lisa we
knew you were coming so we had to go
back into our vault here you are in a
music video in 1982 this is the band ABC
I'm walking and working it ah I'm not
don't know who's that different at least
I think you've got more gorge is almost
kind of dropped a little bit but it's
still there
fierce Lisa Vanderpump
[Music]